Hello, this is uh Victor Davis Hansen
and this is the Victor Davis Hansen in
His Own Word show. We're at the Daily
Signal. You can pick us up there at the
Daily Signal. We have uh a YouTube
presence uh vdansen atx but and you can
get everything at victor hansen hso o n
all one word.com
where every or our podcast both the four
I do a day for the daily signal the
shorts and then our weekly ones we do
with Sammy Wink and Jack Fowler. Today
I'm doing one of our interviews solo
and my guest I think you all know him
Raymond Raymond Ibraham and he's going
to talk about the swords the two swords
of Christ and um
I should say before we start Ry how long
have we known each other 30 what year
did you uh enroll in Cal State Fresno
>> yeah we've known each other um I know I
met you in 1998 [laughter]
>> 90 that was your first here at Cal
State?
>> No, I think I was there in 97, but I
think the first seme like the second
semester is when we met. I had a class
several classes with you.
>> So that would put us in 2026. That's uh
18 years.
>> I mean, I'm sorry, 28
>> 28 years. Ry was a master's student in
Greek and Latin at Cal State Fresno when
I met him and he wrote his thesis with
me. And then
you came to prominence with your was the
al-Qaeda reader your first book.
>> Yeah. My first book um came out in 2005.
Not soon thereafter. Not soon after
leaving college. I was at the Library of
Congress working there.
>> Yeah. Why don't you tell us about that a
couple of minutes? How did you find this
and what was it?
>> Sure. So I was at the Library of
Congress working in the Arabic division
with Arabic.
>> You were you were in graduate school at
that time?
>> I was at Yeah. We I had just graduated
from Fresno and um I went on to
Georgetown University. I was at the
center of contemporary Arab studies
[snorts] and uh you know I didn't
understand the political dimension of
all that at the time and uh but I did
well in grades. I got A's and whatnot
and I landed an internship at the
Library of Congress and then that became
a full-time job and then sometime around
2005 I came across writings by Osama bin
Laden and Aean Zahari the al-Qaeda
leaders.
>> Where did you find it? Where did you
find it?
>> In the Library of Congress, right where
I worked because as a only
>> employ how how you do where was it? What
was it doing?
>> Only employees have access to the stacks
and these are humongous stacks of course
Library of Congress and there's tons of
bins and as part of my cataloging that
that was part of my job, but I would
also peruse through books anyway just
for fun.
>> And um I came across these writings by
Osama bin Laden which were in Arabic. I
investigated it and found out that even
though the media was of course very
interested in al-Qaeda and disseminating
their communicates to the West, nobody
knew about these. And then as you
recall, I mentioned it to you and um you
connected me with um your agent literary
representative and um
>> Yes. And then we and Glenn Hartley uh
published it with Double Day.
>> With uh um Double Day, we got a we got
we got a book deal of Double Day and it
came out in 2007. Yeah. And I think I
wrote the preface to our introdu
forward. And what was what were the
circumstances? He wrote it and someone
in Egypt had published it and the
library got a hold of it.
>> Yeah. There there were some kinds of
issues going on but he had written these
back a lot of them Osama had written
them in the 80s and it was part of the
Mujahedin Afghanistan base that he was
part of. Um but then later writings from
him there was all these were these were
books that were compilations of writings
and so one chap one one one part would
be Osama bin Laden one would be Aman
Zawari one would be people no one even
recognizes and um what I just found
significant is that up until then the
messages that we were being fed by the
media from Osama bin Laden was the
reciprocal treatment business which is
that we're attacking you because you
attacked us you started it we're
innocent you're the attackers you know
the whole nine yards a grievance mantra.
But what was significant about the
writings that I found which were being
shared only with Arab speakers and
Muslims was they actually sounded now
more like ISIS and they were basically
saying no the war is actually
transcendent. It has nothing to do with
finite political grievances. This is
about jihad. This is about Islam against
infidelity or kufur etc etc. So that's
that was the whole significance and
point
>> and you found and you found you found
the Arab text right you you translate
was it it written in colloquially Arabic
or was it more of a form for formalistic
Arabic?
>> No no it was it was the formal standard
Arabic Quranic Arabic formal standard
Arabic is really based on Quranic
Arabic. So Islamists are especially apt
at that.
>> [laughter]
>> So um then after that you wrote a series
of books that um not all of them but
four more I I as I recall and they all
focused on the intersection if I could
use that academic word or the collision
of the Christian world and the Islamic
world and you you had an you had a
unique perspective because your parents
were Coptic Christian immigrants is that
right from
>> Cairo. Right. Or do they live in Cairo?
>> My father was from Cairo. My mother was
from Alexandria.
>> And you do you still have relatives in
Egypt? Huh?
>> Yeah. Yeah, I do.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> The um the next book that after it was
crucified again which deal it's the
subtitle is exposing Islam's new war on
Christians and that that is the one that
deals with the contemporary Musl
contemporary modern-day Muslim
persecution of Christians which the
media completely ignores and uh which as
you indicate I have a personal interest
to due to my own ethnic background being
Coptic and whatnot and my own familial
contacts. So that's what that was that
book. Um and then later on actually I
started gravitating back towards my
academic interests from our days and I
think the the next most popular the
really the most popular book at that
point was sword and scimitar 14
centuries of war between Islam and the
west which came out in 2018 and that was
really a continuation of my master's
thesis which I wrote under your
direction. Uh, you know, chapter one was
the battle of Yarmmuk, which was my
master's thesis, but I reworked it. And
also, I was thinking the other day, you
know, I one of the decisive battles in
Sword and Scimitars is the battle of
Manzakert, and that reminds me of how,
you know, our our mutual friend James
and I actually did a presentation on
that battle in one of your classes.
>> Yes. Rey is uh referring to uh a student
that I had and he was a colleague of Ry,
a Greek and Latin student and he I think
in many ways he was a certified genius
as far as languages go. He was
absolutely a brilliant student um very
eccentric loner. I'm being euphemistic.
And then he went to graduate school in
Penn State and then I lost track of
James. That was too bad because he was a
uh a very interesting guy and he was is
absolutely brilliant. But you kept
you've kept up with him, haven't you?
>> Yeah. Yeah, we're I mean we haven't
probably spoken in a year, but I have
his contact info and I'll I'll probably
be in touch with him soon. But yeah, the
way you describe him is very apt and
you'll be pleased to know he hasn't
changed in any significant way
[laughter]
>> except age. We're all getting older. So
what was uh so let's go to the new book
title and give me a a brief all of our
readers want to have a brief just what's
it about? Sure, Victor. So, it's uh it's
called the two swords of Christ and the
subtitle is the five five centuries of
war between Islam and the warrior monks
of Christendom and here it is and um
it's basically so you know I just
mentioned sword and scimitar where I
looked at the long war between the west
and Islam via decisive battles right so
the battle of yarmmuk manzurt as I
mentioned and then my the other book
between sword and scimitar and this
defenders of the west I looked at what I
call decisive men so western warriors
who fought against Islam. Most of people
and most people don't have any idea
about these guys and or they don't
understand how their actual
significance. So anyway, one book was
about, you know, decisive battles, one
was about decisive men. This book is
kind of in between. It's really um a
long history and it came out to be
really a history mostly of the Crusades
because I'm writing about the Templars
and the Hospitalers, the two primary
military orders. And if you're going to
talk about them, you're obviously going
to talk about the Crusades because they
were literally the backbone of the
Crusades. But it also spills past the
Crusades. As you know, the Knights of
St. John in roads and then later in
Malta. So really the book uh covers from
right at the end of the first crusade
where the Holy Land is now secured under
crusader rule all the way until the
siege of Malta in 1565. I actually go
further. I go until Napoleon basically
conquers Malta and evicts the knights of
the hospital, the hospitalers. Um, so
it's a long history and I think it's
very eye opening um because it like
defenders of the West it truly
underscores heroism and uh the re the
reason for the title is a kind of like a
two twopronged pun because it's called
the two swords of Christ because I'm
referencing the the verse in Luke where
you know Christ tells his disciples sell
your garments and buy a sword and they
say look Lord here are two swords and he
says that's enough. Now that has been
allegorized into absolute
meaninglessness today by Christians, it
just means nothing really. But for a lot
of preodern and especially medieval
Christians and I quote a lot of them,
what it meant is that you know Christ
was saying there's two forms of swords.
One to fight spiritual forces which
modern day Christians I think will agree
with and but the other was to fight
secular physical corporeal forces, evil
humans, right? And so that's how it was
preached and that's what gave rise and
that's uh that's what actuated the
military orders because on the one hand
it's ironic when you look at them the
way they come out in the book they're so
immensely pious they're essentially
monks but at the other on the other hand
they're so immensely ferocious and
militant so it's kind of a strange
fusion uh that occurred back in that era
and one which of course to modern day
Christians is wholly anacronistic
if not if not blasphemous I'm sure but
that's why I I think it's very
interesting to look at the theological
underpinnings which and it goes all the
way back to um St. Augustine just war
theory but [clears throat] I also called
it the two swords of Christ because I
realized quickly that these two military
orders were really the ascendant ones
the templars and the hospitalers. So my
argument is by by really believing in
the concept of the two swords of Christ
that there's a war against spiritual and
physical they themselves became the two
swords of Christ. So as you can see the
pommel uh one one one of the pommel of
the two swords is the templars and one's
the hospitalers. Okay. So yeah that's
it. It's just a long
>> Yeah. Why don't tell everybody I think
is curious
uh make the distinction in the size of
the orders chronologically? Do they
overlap? Which was first? Which was more
prominent? Which was what what separates
them both in faith or actual performance
on the battlefield or their legacy? M
[clears throat] well so the hospitalers
are older but kind of new newer so it's
hard to explain but they existed as an
order first and what they were was they
were just it was a hospice uh for
pilgrims traveling from Europe to the
holy land and they needed obviously
someone there a Christian to provide
them with some relief a place to live a
place to sleep and and often times
medical uh aid so it was a hospice
formed around [snorts] the holy supplr
the church of the holy where were of
course the primary destination for um
for pilgrims but they were not militant
at all. So it actually it's right around
maybe 260s or 270 is when this hospital
by an Amalfi Italian merchant group
actually is the um is they laid the
foundations of it back then this so the
first military group is really the
Templars and right after the first
crusade after Jerusalem the holy land
has been secured it's obviously still a
it's still a small island of
Christianity and a sea of hostile Islam
and so what would happen is even though
lots of Europeans started go going there
on pilgrimages is, but they would still
be attacked and savaged and mauled in
really horrific ways. Okay? I mean, just
very uh shocking, atrocious, raided our
ways, let's just say. And um so
eventually something needed to be done
and [snorts] a small group of knights
decided they were going to commit them
their lives to just they to becoming
monks essentially on the one hand and on
the other hand protecting pilgrims and
that they became the knights of the temp
the templars because they were giving
Baldwin and I think the second gave them
the temple uh ala mosque but they
understood it as Solomon's temple and
that became the residence and they were
essentially they were founded around
1119 but they became formally recogn
recognized at a major council 10 years
later in 1129 and at that point um you
know they they really started growing.
Now the hospitalers were still at this
time functioning as a hospice and and
providing medical aid and relief for
pilgrims but they slowly followed suit
and became militarized and they've fully
become militarized right around maybe
1170 or late mid mid 1170s but uh it's
interesting to see the logic of both
groups because they both start off very
pious and they become immensely militant
as I was saying which seems like a
strange contradiction but if you look
especially at the case of the
hospitalers. These are people whose
entire vows were based on serving our
lords the sick. That was actually part
of the one of their prayers which is to
ser to give their beds to the poor and
needy and etc. And before long they
realized you know the best way to serve
these pilgrims was instead of just
sitting back and waiting until they get
savaged and mauled as they inev
inevitably did by surrounding Muslims,
we will preemptively put a stop to it by
actually protecting them and even going
on the offensive. And so that's why
before long both groups in in as much as
they still maintained their primary
duties of protecting pilgrims and
serving them via hospices became in the
end more just seen as the ultimate crack
troops of Christendom versus Islam
>> in in Jerusalem. The is this the last
generation of the Christian um domain in
Jerusalem before Saladine takes it when
they what what happened after they did
they go to the lesser fortresses in the
holy land?
>> Oh, you're talking about after when
Saladin takes Jerusalem.
>> Yes. Yeah. So, what I was describing is
before that and uh they still have
Jerusalem and all these other Christian
kingdoms after Jerusalem is taken in
1187 by Saladin. um they actually become
even as time goes by and Muslims become
stronger Saladin posts Saladin less and
less aid comes from Europe and more and
more secular native Christians who
native you know the Franks that had been
there for generations sell or donate
their properties and go back to Europe
and so what happens is they really start
taking charge that's why I say they're
really the backbone of the crusades the
templars and hospitalers especially as
the years go by so after uh Jerusalem is
conquered most of them they're Now they
had a series of castles all over the
place and fortifications which were very
important and um in fact it's it's well
known and I document this but without
them they don't get this kind of credit
but without them the holy land would
have been lost much much earlier so they
really uh you know they were the the
primary reserve group that just kind of
kept Sal and Salin there's all these
anecdotes where he was so frustrated
with them this is why by the way after
the battle of Hatin in 1187 even though
Salin the great magnanimous Salon is
known to ransom um you know, Christians
and and whatnot. When it came to them,
both groups, he said, "No, there's no
ransom for them. It was either convert
to to Islam and renounce Christianity or
die." And he had something like 300 of
them uh ritually beheaded at the field.
>> Why did they have such a in popular
imagination? Ridley Scott, you remember
Ridley Scots? I'm just doing it by
memory, but Kingdom of Heaven where they
they're almost portrayed as buffoonish,
aren't they?
>> That's just that's just part for the
course, Victor. any movie I watch about
the Crusades, it's like the more mil the
more uh the more really involved in the
Crusade and serious and taking the
religion, the more buffoonish they
appear and comical and that you know for
and the best one you're mentioning is
you know you're talking about the
kingdom of heaven is Rayald who's this
crazy you know he's a loose cannon and
he's such a hypocrite and he just uses
>> I think he played in the actor Praveden
Braveheart.
>> Yeah. Yeah. that guy, I don't know his
name, but yeah, that he's like Scottish
or Irish
>> and um kind of rotund larger fellow.
Anyway, he's I like him. He's he's a
good actor, but um
>> if you actually look at the sources and
I talk about it in the book, he actually
the real Rainald uh Saladin when he
killed him because he does kill him
actually offered him Islam or renounce
Christ. And Reald gives this really, you
know, heroic speech and basically says,
"I won't do what you want." And that's
when he cuts his head off. That's a
little more heroic than the sort of
buffoonery that ice water or something.
He drank ice and Jeff the the other um
in Kingdom of Heaven was it Jeffrey
uh that I'm trying to remember in the
film the the other evil person who was
married
>> I think it's King Gee Gee
>> Gee. Yeah. And he he ended up in Cyprus,
I think.
>> Yeah, he did.
>> He he did, didn't he? He survived.
>> Yeah. So uh so they after the crus say
after the fourth crusade
they uh they're attred and they start to
disperse into the eastern Mediterranean.
>> These
>> well no after the fourth crusade you
have the fifth crusade which was almost
successful. It's one of the least known
and it's the one that u targeted Egypt.
>> Yes.
>> You know they conquered Damatia and uh
then they went to uh Mansura by Cairo.
Um, but they, you know, there's all
kinds of reasons. I I have several
chapters on the fifth crusade. And
again, the Templars and the Hospitalers
really shine out, especially again, and
I I quote a lot of primary sources
>> to show you what how they were seen.
>> Where if I if are they are the primary
sources in Arabic, Latin, Greek, and Old
French, or what what are they in
English?
>> Yeah, exactly. It's Latin, Old French,
Arabic, a little bit of Greek. Um, but
most of them I would say in Latin in old
French, William of Tears Chronicles is
of course indispensable,
you know, the Rothlin Chronicle, the
Templar of Tier, um, or is that his
name? Um, yeah, I think the Templar of
Tier, who wasn't a Templar, and these
are all eyewitness chronicle sources.
The itinerarium peraganorum by an
anonymous um, chronicler who, you know,
that's the primary third crusade
chronicle. So we're lucky to have a a
plentiful supply of primary sources and
again yeah a lot of them are from the
Muslim Arabic side which and I and as
usual I like to use both so everyone
knows how both in fact I conclude the
book by quoting from Arabic sources
because in many ways they're the ones
who most underscore the how they feared
the Templars and the hospitalers and in
a way it's almost like a begrudging kind
of nod of respect that they give to
them. They always re regularly portray
them as their chief thorn, the ultimate
problem. They talk about other monks and
clergy as being hypocrites. You can buy
them off, but not the Templars and the
hospitalers. And these are internal
dialogues between Muslim strateg
strategists. I think people forget
sometimes because of the contemporary um
narratives that come out of the Middle
East of settler colonialists that you
can make the argument that that area of
the world, Asia Minor and then the
Middle East as well. Um was settled by
Westerners
um you can argue the Ionians were there
from the 7th to 8th century BC. But in
terms of um you know there were Persian
inroads and occupations in Lydia and and
then down in the Holy Land.
You can argue that after the Alexandrian
conquest of the Persian Empire,
that area remained
uh western and then Roman or I should
say eventually Roman and then Henistic
and then Roman and then Christian under
the Bzanti Bzantine. And it wasn't lost
really to the 7th century AD, was it?
>> And that's the great irony. You know
most people today you mention you know
Mina the Middle East and North Africa
and it's in everyone's mind it's of
course it's Muslim but it's almost
always been Muslim always been eastern
okay when in fact at the 7th century
during the Islamic conquest when they
were first when they first begin right
around 636
um that was really the heart of the
Greco Roman Christian world. Yes, it
was. That's
>> think about it. There were five
>> there's five
>> was at Hippo and Augustine of Hippo
Alexandria and and just from a Christian
point of view, you had five major seas.
Only one was in the west, Rome. That's
the one that never got conquered. All
the other four and they were equally as
important. Some arguably were more
important in the earlier like Alexandria
especially. These were all conquered and
absorbed and swallowed up. So if you
look at a map actually Islam swallowed
up literally some somewhere between 66
to 75% of the original Christian world
and later Anatolia Asia Minor was taken
Turkey and people are not aware of this
they just think as really Europe was the
final bastion of Christendom it wasn't
always you know Europe is Christian and
you know the Middle East is Muslim it
was people forget that long painful
traumatic annexation of the majority of
the Christian world which is now Muslim
>> did in did the two orders find them
their way into
Byzantine Constant Constantinople before
1453 didn't were they traveling through
they weren't based in do they have the
protection of the Byzantine Empire at
any point
>> not really and you know to their credit
both orders and this is good for me this
was a happy coincidence for me because
as I mentioned earlier the book I cover
the the crusades in detail but I don't
talk about the fourth crusade because
the book is about these two groups and
they had nothing to do with the fourth
crusade because they were localized in
the holy land. That was their primary
interest which was securing the holy
land and they didn't really get involved
in all of these Byzantine literally
Byzantine labyrinth kind of minations
and whatnot
>> but they were western Christians rather
than orthodoxy.
>> Yeah, they were Catholic.
>> Yes. Yeah. So, and then tell us a little
bit how they got into or these orders uh
established
um a center and roads and then later in
Malta. All right. Well, and I don't want
to give too too much away because this
is actually if you when you read the
book, it's almost like a dramatic movie.
You know, there's so many ups and downs,
but you know, I think everyone knows the
part that they get evicted out of the
Holy Land. You know, the crusades end
right around 1291 and everyone's out and
that's where that's when the knights of
the hospital eventually land in roads,
the island of roads. And that's very
hospital there now today.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You're familiar with
it and I'm sure you're familiar with the
dragon slayer.
>> Yes. Yeah.
>> And I have a whole chapter on that
because that's also interesting. But so
they land in roads and again it really
underscores how dedicated they were to
getting the Holy Land. The roads as you
can see is very close to the Middle East
and it's right off you know the western
coast of of Turkey and they chose it
intentionally. It was actually they they
landed there and settled it right when
the Ottoman Turks were beginning their
epitomis founder Ottoman or Osman was
actually a contemporary with the knights
of St. John when they settled roads and
so um he even attacked them but my point
is they chose that location because
unlike other Christians or crusaders who
wanted the safety they always put
themselves in the most dangerous area so
they can provide sucker and aid for
fellow Christian who are pilgrims or
even more like they actually became a
naval force at this point. So the
knights of St. John right around the
14th century when when they leave the
the Holy Land now they're really a naval
force and they're considered
>> who was who was their who were their
precursors in the terms of the Templars
or the hospitalers who who were their um
>> their founders kind of.
>> Yeah. I mean which which strain of these
Christian militant orders do they emerge
from?
>> Okay. So um the Templars it was a knight
named Hugh Hugh of Pines. I don't know
if I'm pronouncing that right. French
knight and um he was the one who came up
with the idea that we have to create a
band of knights to help protect pilgrims
when they come to the holy land and
initially I something like according to
William of Tier for the first decade
there was just nine knights and they
shared a horse two two knights shared
one horse that's how impoverished they
were that's why their emblem one of
their emblems was you see a knight two
knights on one horse that's a reference
to that but they um they were very much
championed by St. Bernard of Clairvo and
um he was a Cistersian. So much of their
rule was based on the Cistersian rule
which is sort of fortuitous because um
it was the most masculine and the most
austere of all the rules at the time. So
that's what I would say is their
background, the Cistersian rule and the
Knights of the Hospital were more um I
think they were they followed the
Augustinian rule more and um their
founder is it's a funny it's in the book
there's a story um his name is Gerald of
Sasso and he was some he was the he was
the main abbott I think working at the
hospice during the first crusade when
the crusaders came and were besieging
Jerusalem in 1099 and um when they found
him he was he was being tortured by the
Muslims, but they kept him around
because he was a hospice worker. So, he
was serving the Muslim warriors by
taking care of their wounds and whatnot.
Um, but he became and he was he's, you
know, he's the thing is when you look at
their lifestyles, these are like saints.
They're not you don't think of them as
militant at all. And then you and this
is what I think so interesting because
on the one hand, they're just, you know,
very pious saints who are crawling on
their hands and knees and praying and
serving the sick. And then on the other
hand, you see just how, you know, the
degree of militancy that they also had,
which again, you know, flies in the face
of the movies that we watch all the time
when you watch, you know, cool Viking
raiders and they're always attacking
these wimpy, weeping, crying monks who
never fight back. Um, you know, was it I
mean, I'm sure there were instances of
that, but it was more often than not,
you know, they had a very militant
mindset. Um, which by the way, I it
brings an interesting thought. I' I'd
like to hear what you think about it.
But going back on this idea of, you
know, um if you watch these these
movies, they always show you the Vikings
and these pagans are presented kind of
cool. You know, they're like us. They're
they don't take religion seriously. They
just want to have a good time, you know,
but then somehow, you know, they they
end up becoming Christian. And the
Christians are also always presented as
weak and feeble and, you know, screaming
and crying. So my question is, if that
was the case, then why did the Vikings
become Christian? Because they were
actually beaten. those weak Christians
actually beat them on the field of
battle, didn't they? I mean, even even
when you talk about um well, the Norman
conquest, they were Hardrada was already
Christian. But my point is, it doesn't
make sense this Gibbons this Gibbons,
you know, this Edward Gibbons theory
where, you know, to be a Christianity
weakened the pagans because really some
of the most ferocious fighters were the
Franks, the Normans, and they were
Christian and they were beating the
pagans. So, what do you think?
>> I think there were two reasons. one was
they were very impressed with the Roman
legacy. So in terms of writing
uh aqueducts, roads, architecture,
the especially the Scandinavians, they
did not have that they were [snorts] too
far on the other side of Germany to have
a direct contact
uh with the western and then later
Christian experience. And the other one
was as you know people talk about Islam
as being ecumenical but Christianity
then once you were converted then you
were as much a Christian as somebody
from another nation had been for
centuries. So this this this
Christian missionary zeal had said to
the Scandinavians and the Vikings, if
you can convert, not only will you have
exposure to this superior culture that
will improve your lives, but more
importantly, you're just as important as
we are. You're Christians and we
>> So it puts an end to tribalism, which is
good.
>> Yes. It put it put an end to tribalism.
Although um there are people who have
suggested in given us terms that after
their conversion they were not as um
ruthless or combative as they had been
before. Uh
>> well that's the chivalick culture right?
>> Yes. If people are interested, Gibbons
decline and fall, he makes this argument
that uh it doesn't quite work very well
because he says that they were I don't
want to you colonized or civilized or
the sermon on the mount was not the same
as if you want war, if you want peace,
prepare for war, the Marshall credto of
the Romans. But it doesn't really
explain and remember Gibbons decline and
fall of the Roman Empire goes all the
way to 1453. So somehow from 470 to 1453
one millennium
Christianity in the Roman the Greeks
Byzantines never called themselves
Byzantine that's a 19th century word
they were called Romeoi and they were
Christian and they were very formidable
fierce warriors.
>> Yeah.
>> And so um that that's uh that's
something to keep in mind. Then they get
to Malta when they're expelled from
roads.
Yeah. So after they're expelled in
roads, you know, I call them the
homeless hospitalers and they're just
kind of living on the Mediterranean. And
this is also coincides with the um the
high age of Islamic piracy, the barbar
raids because they get evicted in 1480.
So you know, right around that time, you
have the Barbar Roa brothers who are and
again
>> it's just funny to me when you hear when
you the Barbar Roa and and and the
piracy thing. It's today now al almost
presented almost like in a funny
clownish way. But when you read what
these pirates were doing, I mean they
literally were terrorizing all of
Europe. The kind of it wasn't the the
sadism involved in the atrocities that
they would engage in biting some guy's
throat out and eating his tongue and
twisting someone's head until his eyes
bul bulge out. Really graphic stuff.
It's also the high age of slavery like I
said. So
>> in just in one century they've estimated
it's a very conservative estim estimate
by an American professor where it's 1.2
million white slaves uh just in barbary
were being sold and this doesn't take
into consideration the Ottomans which
was even bigger the Ottoman slave trade
or the Crimean the Tatars which were
Muslim slave trade of basically European
flesh. And so um one of the one of their
chief duties at this point when they're
now in Malta is to is to try to defend
against these slave raids um by the
Ottomans by the Mamlukes as well who are
in Egypt
>> and people should remember that uh
there's been a lot of studies on the
ethnic
>> background of the herum in uh
Constantinople and at most people
believe that half of the people in the
herum were from southern Russia or the
Black Sea And they are from Europe, the
Balkans. And if you think about it, you
know, once the mother, the sultan
married, had his various concubines, but
he picked one to produce an heir,
usually the others were liquidated. And
then the Sultan was half European. And
if you keep doing that again and again
and again, people have argued that many
of the sultans by the 15th or 16th
century were European. And Erdogan and
his arrogance got very angry when the
Greeks said that they not only had been
there since the 7th century BC in Asia
Minor, but that the Byzantine Empire
uh DNA still existed. So he he uh
commissioned 23 and me to have done a
study of Turkish rural people and they
found out that the vast majority of them
had more Greek blood than Turkish
>> slaves.
>> Yes, slaves. And then the elite were uh
from the herum as well. And
>> the issue that you're talking about,
this elite thing, it's even worse. It's
not that they were half. Um actually,
there's a Spanish scholar who looked at
the Omiads in Spain.
>> Yes.
>> And he determined that the very last
khalif had something like only 5% Arab
blood and 95% European blood because it
was like you say, it was always split in
half because they would always mate with
Europeans. There's a very uh there was a
scholarly study done maybe eight or nine
years ago that pointed out that a lot of
Ottoman foreign policy as it as it was
focused on the Balkans that is not so
much conquest but occupation and
control. Certain villages were exempt
and he studied these villages. These
would be places in Greece, what is now
Albania, Turkey, parts of uh Yugoslavia.
And the ones that were treated the best
were the u the homes of the mother of
the Sultan over two or 30 hundred years.
She she had that influence because she
was captured as a young girl, put in the
herum and then ended up luckily as the
queen bee, so to speak. the do you have
the heroic siege of Malta where they
where they stopped?
>> I think I probably have the most
comprehensive account
>> because I went through all the primary
sources and it's something like 40 pages
in my book. But there's also, you know,
everyone knows about the siege of Malta.
It is very heroic. But lesser known and
no less heroic is the uh the 1480 siege
of roads. And I might have misspoken. I
think I said they were evicted in 1480.
Actually in 1480 the largest Ottoman uh
armada came to evict them and they lost.
So they were actually evicted in 1522
um from roads by Sullean the great but
they
>> Hamagusta was another tragedy too the
siege of Hamagustu where they
>> oh there's a lot and um another
especially important is the siege of
what's that
>> they stuffed him you remember with straw
Mark Antonio they
>> Oh yeah you're talking about right
before Leonto
>> yes right before it was
>> yeah that's uh that these are the things
that you know never show up in the
Hollywood movies that are you know
intent on always showing how magnanimous
the Muslims Yeah, they had been given
terms and then uh they broke the the
deal and slaughtered the uh Venetians.
>> Y
>> it was horrific. But um
>> the slavery part though,
>> I think I think you'll like the slavery
part. I think every I think not you but
I think everyone every American will
really benefit from looking at the
slavery data because what else comes out
in in this book um because I I talk a
lot about the slavery of Europeans was
that there was a unlike the
transatlantic slave trade of blacks
which was really cold business. It was
you know the way it comes off it's just
cold business. The Muslim enslavement of
the Europeans had an ideological
component to it because you're the
enemy, you're the infidel, you're the
Christian. So they were always treated
in very very sadistic ways which comes
out in the book. Um and also you know
speaking of the black slave trade
whereas blacks in America and this again
here here's a reflection of something
today that we can talk about that
reflects on the past. So today America
still has a significant black population
because they continue to exist. Slavery
the enslavement of black Africans during
by Muslims and Arabs was even more
widespread. But if you look at the DNA,
yeah, it was about 30% larger than the
>> But if you look at the DNA of those
regions, they have zero black blood and
that's because they would castrate them
all and uh and often times just kill
them. So they never had a chance to
assimilate. So this is what I'm saying.
Islamic slavery, all slavery is bad
obviously, but the Islamic slavery came
with all these different really sadistic
components that that most historians
overlook.
>> We're going to take a quick break. We'll
be right back with Raymond Ibraham. And
he is the author of a new book that is
coming out. What's the uh pub date?
>> It comes out November 25th.
>> November 25th. You should get it right
before Thanksgiving
um The Two Swords of Christ. And we'll
be right back.
And we're back from uh our sponsors and
we're here with Rabin Ibraham. And I I I
think because slavery is such a hot
button topic 1619 project. People don't
even realize the word Slav, you know,
slave, it comes from the idea these are
uh originally white captives from the
Balkans who were Slavic. And there were
three or four million of them um
enslaved by the Ottomans. And the some
of it's pretty I don't know the whole
psychology of the janiseries is kind of
sick. you know, they would go into a
recruitment village and pick pick out a
blondhaired, blueeyed,
>> big child and say, you know, we'll only
take one of your sons, but uh he'll have
a great career. Then they segregate him
and make him into a zealot. Um Islamic.
>> If I may elaborate on that because
you're really touching on an important
topic and the worst part isn't even what
it was, it's how it's being presented
today. So it it is what you say, which
was basically they conquer a subject and
the janiseries first of all were all
white. They were all Europeans. That was
that was the case. So they would go,
they'd conquer whatever some some eur
Balkan nation and then they would go and
take, like you're saying, the
healthiest, the strongest, the
handsomest boys, and then they would
find what they're good at. If they're
big and strong, they would turn them
into warriors, janiseries. If they were
just handsome or smart, they would use
them as administrators. But they would
also go through a systematic Islamic
indoctrination process. And they would
get them pretty young. Okay? So a lot of
them would really become Muslims. And
then the sick psychology is that you
know it was a perpetual cycle. So they
would radicalize these guys who were
originally Christians and then unleash
them on their former kin to take to
conquer more land and take again that
that so they were literally bleeding
them of their best and strongest.
>> We have a lot of we have some Byzantine
sources about that about the shot.
>> But now as you know in the academic
sources today you know how they describe
Janiseries it's like getting a uh
scholarship to Harvard.
No, it I I mean there's something the
dervish it's it's something about this
recruitment when you're a Balkan u
peasant and an Islamic army comes in and
you see these big
European looking soldiers and they have
a particular distinctive you know
feather I mean on their cap and their
helmet everything about them and they're
the best trained and the most uh
equipped and yet they're one of you and
in some cases we even have anecdotes
where people recognize families
recognize some of the janis janiser and
yet they're the most bloodthirsty
anti-Christian
>> and they were also here's an an
interesting point that goes along with
one of your with one of your thesis um
from way way back they were always
infantry and I think that's because the
Ottomans understood that Europeans made
for good decisive shock troops
[laughter]
>> the western way of war
>> yeah they were sort of the Ottoman
uh SS.
>> Yeah.
>> Where does where does the book end?
>> Uh it ends uh I the the major scene
major ending scene is the siege of Malta
in 1565 and I start it right around the
first crusade 1100. But I have like a
chapter that kind of summarizes what
happens all the way until really the
present but mostly with um Napoleon's
conquest of Malta on his way to Egypt
right around 1800.
tell us what did Napoleon do with with
the um the order when he got the when he
disbanded it. It's well it's really
funny you know the whole thing is it
just shows you how things had changed
because a lot of as you know most of the
crusaders historically including of the
military orders were Franks which means
they were French so it's ironic today
when you think of France is so secular
and and you know all all this sort of
thing um but they were actually they
they created most of the the till today
in Arabic if you say ephrangi which
means frankie it means a white guy or or
you can if you say it about an Arab guy
he's frangi means he's he acts He acts
western. Okay. So that's how that's the
impact that Franks had on. So it's
ironic that a Frenchman you know these
this military order the Knights of St.
John lasted for what uh you know almost
a thousand years and um it was actually
a French man who put an end to them and
he had a Quran in his possession which
he was reading cuz he was on his way to
Egypt and he was trying to
diplomatically enex it which he kind of
did. Um so he didn't kill them he just
basically evicted them and they
continued. They still live till today.
The Knights of St. John still exist.
>> I've I've had I was giving a lecture I
think it was in Vienna or um it was in
Vienna or it was in um Geneva where
somebody came up to me and said he was a
European aristocrat and he was from the
Order of St. John and he had this
[laughter] kind of he opened a little
case and he had a red stash and
everything and
>> but they've been demilitarized. So, you
know, their hallmark thing that made
them impressive is no longer they're
more, you know, they're involved in
charity and uh you know, um earthquake
relief. All of which is great. Of
course, it's very funny. It's the value
of going back. I think all of our
listeners and viewers understand is it
it really puts today's um particular
views in in a larger context. If you
look what's going on with Boo Haram in
Nigeria, two two million refugees,
160,000 Christians slaughtered, and you
look at the world's attention on the
so-called settler colonialist Israelis
in the Gaza compared to what's going on
uh in the occupation of Nigeria or
northern Cyprus where a whole um a whole
demographic in 1973
74 was ethnically cleansed. And I I
don't know how Islam has been able to
achieve this euphemistic
both in vocabulary and the way that we
look at I guess it I don't know if it's
out of fright of terrorism or it was the
chauvinism came from the power of oil in
the 70s and 80s with the boycotts but
people have not applied the same
standards of evaluation when you look at
so-called genocide atrocity occupation
all of these buzzwords that we associate
with Israel in the Middle East. It's
really shocking.
>> The worst part for me um that I'm
noticing, and I haven't heard anyone say
this, but it really um complements what
you're saying is that um there's this
weird seessaw between Israel as a nation
and Islam as a religion. And um it seems
to me that for the longest time there
was it's like an eitheror exclusive uh
kind of thing, which is one is if one's
bad, one's good. If one's good, one's
bad. And for the longest time, I think
the idea was Islam is bad, is violent,
it's tolerant, therefore Israel is good.
Now, as Israel comes under increasing
criticism, all of a sudden, is Islam is
now the good guy. And it's kind of like,
okay, you know what's happening in
Israel and the Palestinians, that's a
very localized thing. But for some
reason now, people are just giving a a
blank pass to Islam anywhere and
everywhere. So, in Africa with this
jihad, in Europe with the migrants, and
it's kind of like it's become this weird
seessaw. So just because Israel now is
under criticism, Islam has been lifted
up and it's above reproach. Weird.
>> I I think a lot of it is to do with
>> the 250,000
um students in universities from the
Middle East here in the United States
and in Europe. And then the immigrant
population of Germany is 15.5,
France is about 9%.
And uh Britain is up to eight or nine
and and even higher in some of the
cities. And so you're getting a huge uh
influx of immigrants from the Middle
East and then consensual societies. They
vote and they have a lot of influence.
And then there's always the fear of
terrorism. We remember
um the cartoonist in Paris and we've
known as the writers van go all these
people who were threatened for uh
Solomon Rushi. So there was always a
sense that a Christian militant for no
matter what the left said about you know
prolifers they were pretty calm but
there was the idea that there are more
and more Islamic peoples in the west now
in the last 30 years and we always have
to be careful how we talk because we can
get an uh you know we can have a
terrorist incident in a way that will
not happen with other groups and there's
a lot of wealth now petro in the Middle
East. Gutter I think gave $50 million
the last 10 years to universities. Most
of the Middle East programs u in the
elite schools are funded by m middle
east pro dollars mostly from gutter.
>> I found that out the hard way when I
went to Georgetown.
>> Yeah, I bet they they've got they've got
more money than I think anyone I think
it's last I looked like I don't know 50
million uh since the like early 2000s.
>> Yeah. And it definitely
>> Yeah, it definitely right next to the
capital. It's it's a university. It's
the best university in Washington DC and
>> it's it affects everything and uh it
affects where I work and it's hard to um
speak. Another thing is that the Jewish
population in the United States is about
7 million and the Arab population used
to be a fraction of that. It's about 3
1/2 to 4 million and by 3 uh 2030 it's
supposed to surpass it. But more
importantly, the secularization of the
Jewish uh diaspora in the United States
is really a almost half of Jews do not
uh are not observant and 30 or 40% are
not particularly fond of Israel and that
is not true of the Islamic Muslim
population. they are they do not uh
abandon or secularize or intermar of the
same frequency as Jews. So I think we're
going to get in a situation a situation
very soon that the lobbying in the
Middle East is going to flip in the
United States that the there's going to
be more adherence and more student and
political activism on the behalf of
Hamas or Hezbollah or or the Houthis or
Iran
uh than there is Israel. I can already
feel it. And that in a democracy you'll
feel that people will make the necessary
adjustments in politics. They already
have the Democratic party 40% of them
support Israel 40% and it's almost 72 or
73 in the Republican side. So I it's
this ancient strife that you're talking
about in your series of books, but
especially this one. It's very very
relevant today. Excuse me.
>> That's exactly it. It's the continuity
that I've always found um eyeopening.
You know, people treat what's happening
today as if it's, you know, it's its own
particular local new development, but
it's not because you, you know, you, so,
for example, going to this point about
now that Israel's criticized, Islam is
good. Well, how do we explain the
previous 2,000 years or 14 centuries
between Islam and the West when Israel
didn't exist and Islam was doing the
same exact thing against the West and
conquering and you know and people don't
realize America's very first war as a
nation is with Muslims, not just
Muslims, you know, Barbary Wars, but
when Jefferson and Adams asked them, why
are you attacking our vessels and
enslaving our people? the the ambassador
from Barbara, he said, "Because our
Quran says you're infidels and it's our
duty to terrorize and kill and enslave
you." He literally said that and
Jefferson wrote it to Congress and we
have the letter. So that's why it's I
just find it interesting because uh
what's happening today and political
developments really have don't really
shed light the way people think they do
on Islam's relationship with the West.
Um, but as far as your point about the
left and Islam, um, in fact, just last
week I looked at a really important
report and it was about the rise of
anti-Christian sentiment throughout
Europe and it's also happening in the
North America as well, attacks on
churches especially. And um, you know,
when you dig into it, you find out,
well, who are the two primary culprits
behind this these attacks on churches?
One, it said Islamists and two,
leftists. So, you find they're always in
bed together even though on the surface
they're so different.
>> Yeah. It's very funny how uh on the new
binary that neo-Marxist binary that
we've I think since Obama we've divided
the country to oppressed oppressor
victim victimizer
under that DEI paradigm it's not just
gender and race or ethnicity it's
religion and somehow a somehow and it
has nothing to do with class because
take Mandami as I pointed out on this
show before He's his Indian-Americans,
that is Americans whose legacy comes
from the Indian subcontinent or the
wealthiest immigrant group in the United
States. And yet he talks about taxing
affluent and white neighborhoods. But my
point is that um somehow
uh very prosperous young students from
the Middle East fueled by petro dollars
and they're the elite of their society.
They get over here and then they're they
become part of the DEI DEI coalition
intersectional
and you can be a middle class Jewish kid
and then you're demonized as a settler
colonialist oppressor and it has nothing
to do with history or class or money or
anything. And it it's just stunning. And
then when you look at the LGBT
community and what would happen if any
of these people in that coalition were
to go back uh to the Middle East and
lived there, I can tell you that as
somebody who's visited Israel a lot and
visited the West Bank and even Gaza, I
can tell you that if you were openly
LGBTQ with a pride flag and you had a
choice between walking on a corner in
Tel Aviv or in Ram Amada. Uh, excuse me.
I would say probably
Gaza City, Bethlehem, anywhere in the,
uh, West Bank or Gaza, you would be in
dire trouble.
>> Are you familiar with what happened in
Ham Tramik, Michigan?
>> Uh, lately, yes, I was. That's near
Dearborn, isn't it?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if it's lately,
but it really goes to what you're saying
because it finally [snorts] um the the
leftist, the LGBT crowd um really
supported the Muslim migrant community
there in many ways until they became
literally the majority. And once they
became uh the majority of the city
council, the first thing they did is ban
pride [laughter]
and the and the LGB felt so betrayed and
upset and uh but that to me I think is
the modus operende moving forward for
any leftist who wants to work with them.
Oh, I don't think I mean I'm not
suggesting they're not moderate Muslims,
but to be a moderate Muslim in Muslim
orthodoxy is not to be a Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it doesn't it doesn't have the
liberalizing evolutionary strains and
sex that Christianity has.
>> A moderate Muslim is just an assimilated
Muslim who's more American than he is
Muslim. You know, it's just he's a
nominal Muslim. that can happen but not
to the same degree as um Christianity.
Let's uh before we go, Ry, if somebody
wants to buy the book, you go to Amazon,
you can get it, but what's your website?
So, they can go there.
>> Sure. Thanks, Victor. My website um is
raymond Ibrahim.com. R A Y M O N D I B R
Ah i M. And uh links to all my books to
Amazon, but also if you want to get a
signed copy, you can get it through my
website. And also, um, I got my little
YouTube channel which I've been growing.
Uh, goes under my name.
>> What is that? Under
>> Raymond Ibrahim's Holy War channel.
>> Holy [laughter] War channel.
>> It seems applicable.
>> I'm surprised you weren't under the
previous administration survey by the U.
[laughter]
>> Well, I made it afterwards.
>> The the FBI. And uh, what's the
publisher where they could go?
>> Uh, the publisher of the two swords of
Christ is Bombardier Post Hill.
>> Oh, good. Bombader is a new imprint by
Adam Bellow, the son of Saul Bellow,
isn't it? He was my editor for eight
books.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh he was a very good guy. So he he's
got his own imprint now. Bombader Books.
>> It's by the way, it's got really uh I'm
very happy with the um not only the
maps, but the uh color pictures.
>> Wow, that's amazing.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of nice color
pictures in there.
>> That's a lot of work to get all the
pictures and permissions and everything.
>> So here's the there's a there's a
Templar charge. There's the, you know,
the two nights I was talking about on
one horse.
>> Um,
>> and uh you can everybody you can buy it
uh tomorrow.
>> Tomorrow.
>> You can buy it now, but and you'll
probably get it tomorrow. Uh
>> and are you going to be appearing
anywhere, Ray, at book signings or I
know you're traveling a lot in the next
few weeks.
>> Yeah. Um not necessarily book signings,
but yeah, maybe I'll do one. Maybe
you'll do maybe I can do a local one.
>> Yes, you can. And you're uh on your way
to Europe, is that right? Pretty soon.
>> Yeah. Yeah, I'm going uh to Europe. I'm
going to be there for a little bit. Um
for a while, possibly.
>> Where are you going to be?
>> I'm going I'm going to be at the uh
Well, must I say because people might
come try to kill me.
>> Oh, I want You don't have to tell. Yeah.
Don't
>> I'm a haunted guy.
>> Yeah. Well, I have people showing up my
house as well.
>> I know.
>> Yeah. I've had that problem. I've uh as
I told my
>> But you know what? I'll say this. It'll
be in Hungary.
>> Okay. which is relatively safe. I guess
>> I needed some um Knights of Malta when
people they swattered our home. You know
this they called up and said there was
an armed intruder and all these armed
sheriffs came and then I walked into I
won't tell you the branch. I walked in
or the bank and I was going to take
money out and they said, "We're sorry,
Mr. Hansen. You have no savings and you
have no checking account." They drained
it. So who are they? Who are they? as
they say in the Wild Bunch. I don't know
who they are, but I can tell you one
thing that um they're not on the
conservative side.
>> I've been, you know, I've been to your
ranch many times and it's it looks
increasingly like a belleaguered night
fortress [laughter]
surrounded by hordes.
>> Yeah. Well, uh I had a a local law
enforcement officer that not too long
ago gave me a oral map. I mean, he
delivered a little discourse on the
incidents of gang violence, murder,
theft, assault, and he said,
"Unfortunately for you, the intersection
closest to you is the most heavily
crimeridden in my area of southwest
Fresno County. And one day, not too long
ago, I was driving into town and all of
a sudden I saw maybe 15 people.
Some were ICE and they did have the mask
but some were uh DEA um drug enforcement
agency. Some were FBI and they all had
mask
uh and then they had about 15 people in
boxer shorts
and they were all handcuffed with
plastic and they were all sitting there
and it's funny because we didn't know
what was going on. We were getting, you
can go on Google and we were getting
things like
a person would come and say
and I said no sir. And he and it was
there was a house of prostitution on a
Google map but they unfortunately gave
the wrong coordinates to our house. So,
we had everybody showing up in our
barnyard and then we've had one where
you could get car quote unquote car
parts and things like that that people
have asked me for where do I get the car
parts
and and where you live was originally
settled by Swedes, right? Uh well,
Kingsburg was my my father's family, but
this was more
uh people from you know all but it was
considered if you was one ethnic group
in Selma it was Danish and uh D this was
a Danish town and and um Kingsburg was
more Swedish. But when I was growing up,
all of these houses around me were all
the Fukis were Italian.
Uh we had um Japanese, two Japanese
families, we had a Dutch family, we had
a person from India, [clears throat]
a person from Mexico, and two Armenian
families. It was really a natural
diversity, and they were all
>> That was much more homogeneous, huh?
>> Yeah. There's no such thing as
diversity, but it's all corporate. So
when I I walk every night, um, and it's
funny on my property of 40 what's left
of it, it's 40 acres. I I'm just a
tesser in a mosaic. So I see the tractor
of my landlord who owns I don't know
over 10,000 acres. He's a good guy, too.
And he his tractors just go on one
property and then another property and
then and they're all lined up. So when I
get to my little 40 acres, I I wave to
the track. But all the houses um that
used to be the places where kids were
raised, they're all rented out from
people most, not all, but a lot
illegally. And you should see them.
They're they're not farm houses anymore.
They're compounds. So there's Winnebago,
there's leantos, romax, corral. There's
30 40 people living in a compound that
once had a family. And it's nobody knows
who they are. Um I try to keep on good
terms. I've had a couple of film crews
come here. They've heard about this
area. They wanted to film about gang
activity and meth and uh fentinel. And I
said, "Please do not go to that house,
that house, that house, that house." At
least not in my company because I have
to live here. But we do have kind of a
um ashler wall. no turrets, but I built
it with a good friend of mine and it's
700 ft. Anyway, it's it's kind of
isolated. I feel like not that I'm going
to compare myself to Augustine, but I'm
sort of like at the the siege of
Hippoius or something or maybe the the
siege of New Carthage
>> and not the Vandal. Those were vandals,
but that was pretty bad. Can I make do
we have time for if I make a quick
relevant observation and get your
reaction to it?
>> Yes. Yes.
>> So I've been noticing you know a lot of
people when they people living in the
west, Europe, America and so forth the
majority are still white European and um
so when they see minorities around them
I think they still think of themselves
as in having the upper hand. But that's
only a microcosmic view because if you
look at the whole world it seems to me I
think the white population is like 6 7
8%. I I think it's 6 7%.
>> 6%. So what I'm trying to figure out is
and that's the that's the demographic
that little tiny 6% is the one that's
being convinced from cradle to grave
that they have to suppress their
culture, their religion, their
civilization. They have to give up land
to the other because they're horrible
people and somehow they still think
they're in the majority. But in the big
and the people who who they're giving
everything up to land and territory and
conceding would never of course do that
if it was you know vice versa if whites
went to their country. So I'm just
trying to understand is this a purely
suicidal um situation
>> book there's a lot of books called the
suicide of the west obviously
>> literally right
>> yeah there's three or four but um or the
dawn and decadence by Jacques Barzon
>> um I think part of it is is the unique
nature of western civilization it's the
only one that's self-critical you know
when you go back to the plays of
Aristophanes or the dry comments of
lucidities or task Acidus in the Roman
sphere, Swatonius.
No, nobody I can't think of a an Islamic
author or a Chinese author who would
say, you know, we make a desert and call
it peace as um as is in Tacitus's uh
annals, our histories. So, I I don't see
any of that self-criticism. And the West
is very self-reflective. The
enlightenment, that's one thing.
>> And it's being weaponized against it,
though.
>> Yeah, it is. There's a fine line between
hel health healthy self-criticism and
self-critique and self-loathing or what
one of a great scholar is called ooh
phobia hating your own household
of your own culture and that's taken
root partly because uh of the emphasis
on race. The other thing people forget
is western culture um never it while it
it was born in Europe it was it it was a
little bit different um in in the sense
that Japanese is u the Japanese culture
is westernized it's a strong ally of the
United States it's democratic South
Korea is so we've had this propensity to
be able to incorporate people in the
west who were originally either are not
a part of it or antithetical ideas. So
when the founders said, you know, all
men are created equal,
they allowed everybody to come to the
United States. It wasn't like the
Spanish Empire that said you had to be
Spanish and Christian to be admitted
into Latin America or South America or
southern North America. So it's um the
problem with that is
that I think multiculturalism
misinterpreted what the what the idea
was behind America. The idea behind
America was you come from all over the
world but you have to surrender your
prior identity and you have to accept a
western and particularly American
identity and you can enrich us our
culture with your food, your clothing,
your music, your art, but you do not
dare tamper with the core beliefs. And
we have people who are coming here and
they know nothing about the history of
America or they know nothing about the
Constitution
and they think they can operate on the
premises of where they came from. But
you know in a brutal bargain nobody
asked anybody nobody asked my nobody
asked any of us to come here. We all
came here with the idea that it was
better than the alternative and
certainly better than our own homeland.
And once we get here, we should keep
that in mind. I keep going back to this
crazy metaphor. I wrote about it in Mex,
but I think I had a student, I won't
mention his name, he was contemporaneous
with you, and he was really brilliant.
And one day I saw him burning under that
uh Prop 187 that was going to cut off um
state support for illegal aliens, and he
was burning the American flag, and they
all had Mexican flags. So I said to my
student,"Wh are you doing this? You're
waving the flag under no circumstances
you want to go back and you're burning
the one under every circumstance you
want to stay." And he said, 'I don't
know. I'm just angry. [laughter] I said,
"Who are you angry at?" And he said,
"Well, they don't want me here." I said,
"No, they want you here if you're
illegal and you get citizenship, but
they don't want you to come if you're He
was illegal." So I guess what I'm saying
is that we have done a very poor job of
saying to immigrants, you're welcome,
but you must speak our language. You
must be acquainted with our culture. You
must assimilate, acculturate, integrate
within it. We would welcome your
literature and your, you know, your
restaurants and all that enriches us.
But don't dare try to change our
constitutional system and our western
legacy. And if you got somebody on the
left that doesn't believe that, then the
moment you set foot in the United
States, you can be living in Waka,
Mexico, and come up here illegally and
you take one inch inside the United
States and the left says, "Oh, you're
cap you're eligible for DEI for
historical racism and oppression toward
your people in the United States." And
you want to say, "Well, he was never in
the United States. He just was here a
nancond ago." But that's that's I think
that's going to stop because if it
doesn't stop, we know where it is. The
suicide of the West, you know.
>> So, and you who uh do you I know that I
was at a Christian bookstore not long
that that is a u a lot of Christian
bookstores carry your books, don't they?
I've seen
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm I'm [clears throat]
surprised the la these books um which I
are really a trilogy sword and scimitar
defenders of the west and now the two
swords of Christ are you know the other
day they were um in early in the
bestseller early Christian history
Amazon list they were in the top five
>> one four and five that's great
>> are they all published by bombader or
just two
>> bombardier is defenders of the west and
the new one the two swords of Christ and
um the uh sword and scimitar was dapo
hashet
>> uhhuh yeah you should try That would be
a good thing, Ray, if you could get them
in a box set, you know, as a trilogy.
Volume one, two, and three.
>> That would be nice.
>> Yeah, that a lot of authors do that. I
Donald Kagan wrote separately is four
volume history, the Pelponian War. Then
Cornell
>> Press reissued it as a box set. That
would be good. Anyway, we're going to
leave now. Um,
Rey Ibraham, Two Swords of Christ, it's
out. former student of mine but also
companion and friend over the last three
decades. And uh what's final comment?
What are you working on now? What's the
next project?
>> Thanks very much, Victor. Um I'm right
now trying to recover but um uh as far
as books go. Yeah,
>> but I think um I'm actually considering
writing a book that and this is a lot of
this comes from people reacting to these
books, but it would be sort of um
lessons for today from these books from
this long history and sort of an attempt
to uh articulate and reclaim muscular
Christianity as it was understood back
then and which is now of course under
extreme you know attack. Christianity
today is of course just the most
emasculated religion. It's I call it
doorstep doormat Christianity for a lot
of denominations anyway. So I just want
to, you know, recapture that spirit,
rearticulate it, show the theological
underpinnings behind it because there's
a lot like the two swords verse that I
mentioned that most people don't
understand and try to see, you know, how
it can be applied to modern Christians.
So they stop being doormats.
>> Yeah. For students to get a more
disinterested and fair view of the
crusades or
>> the fall of Constantin. Yes. Absolutely.
Well, anybody, thank you very much. This
is Victor Davis Hansen in his own words,
the show. And our guest has been Raymond
Ibraham, and we're going to finish.
We'll see you in a few days. Thank you.
Thank you for tuning in to the Daily
Signal. Please like, share, and
subscribe to be notified for more
content like this. You can also check
out my own website at victoransen.com
and subscribe for exclusive features. In
addition, [music]